la squalophobie vous connaissez c'est la
peur incontrôlable des requins elle
touche de nombreuses personnes et bien
souvent les gens qui n'ont jamais croisé
le moindre requin mais cette mauvaise
réputation est-elle vraiment justifiée
doit-on considérer les requins comme de
dangereux serial Killer's aujourd'hui on
va essayer de comprendre pourquoi les
requins nous rendent marteau
[Musique]
les requins sont arrivés sur Terre bien
avant nous on estime qu'ils sont apparus
il y a 400 millions d'années soit plus
de 150 millions d'années avant les
dinosaures ils ont survécu à 4
extinction de masse actuellement il en
existe environ 500 espèces très
différentes elle peuple tous les océans
les mers chauds des froides et vivent
près de la surface ou dans les
profondeurs le plus petit c'est le
requin chapitre mais il ne dépasse pas
15 cm un peu plus grand c'est celui-ci
le requin baleine c'est aussi le plus
gros poisson du monde enfin ça c'est une
miniature les plus grosses spécimens
mesurent jusqu'à 15 mètres de longueur
environ la taille d'un autobus si vous
en croisez un pas de panique ce requin
est parfaitement inoffensif il ne se
nourrit que de plancton d'algues et de
tout petits poissons au détail seul le
mégalodon aurait pu rivaliser avec lui
un véritable monstre des mers qui a
disparu heureusement il y a 3,6 millions
d'années il y a quelques mois une
fillette américaine a retrouvé sur une
plage du Maryland une dent de mégalodon
fossilisée elle mesure 12 cm de long
regardez la différence avec celle d'un
grand requin blanc qui compte parmi les
plus gros spécimens vivants on pense que
les plus grands mégalodons pouvaient
mesurer jusqu'à 20 mètres de longueur et
contrairement au requin-baleine c'est un
redoutable prédateur
j'aurais pas aimé le croiser celui-là il
faut une méga trouille chez les requins
l'habit ne fait pas le moine celui-ci
par exemple le squale les féroce qui
mesure dans la nature à peine 50 cm est
beaucoup plus susceptible de vous
attaquer que les normes requins baleines
le requin du Groenland lui détient un
autre record c'est le vertébré qui vit
le plus longtemps certains spécimens
seraient âgés de plus de 400 ans vous
l'avez compris les requins constituent
une famille très varie en revanche du
point de vue anatomique ils ont tous un
point commun ils possèdent un squelette
cartilagineux ce qui les distingue des
autres poissons dont le squelette est
constitué d'arêtes et parfois d'os leur
mode de reproduction et lui aussi très
particulier certains requins sont
ovipare il pondent des œufs dans les
fonds marins comme la plupart des
poissons c'est le cas de la roussette
que l'on croise fréquemment en
Méditerranée d'autres sont
trop vivipare leurs œufs se développent
dans le corps de la femelle et éclose
c'est le cas du requin taureau lors
d'une plongée il y a quelques années
j'en ai croisé un enfin une avec son
petit enfin il existe quelques espèces
vivipares comme le requin gris de récif
comme chez les mammifères les petits
requins grandissent dans le ventre de
leur mère à laquelle ils sont reliés par
un cordon mais ce qui est le plus
remarquable chez les squale c'est la
peau elle est constituée de millions de
denticules de petites écailles en forme
de V qu'on appelle écaille placoïde elle
favorise l'écoulement de l'eau en la
canalisant ce qui réduit les frottements
et renforce l'hydrodynamisme de l'animal
grâce à cela ils peuvent se déplacer
rapidement le requin mako par exemple
peut atteindre la vitesse de 70 km/h cet
hydrodynamisme a inspiré des ingénieurs
qui ont synthétisé la peau de requin et
l'ont testé
sur le fuselage des avions résultat
moins de frottement de l'air moins
d'énergie nécessaire pour faire voler
l'appareil et donc un petit peu moins de
kérosène utilisée mais les
particularités des requins ne s'arrêtent
pas là en 400 millions d'années
d'évolution ces animaux se sont dotés
d'un véritable arsenal pour chasser leur
arme principale c'est Louis et les six
fine qu'ils peuvent repérer des proies à
plus d'un kilomètre ils sont aussi dotés
d'un odorat exceptionnel les requins
possèdent deux narines indépendantes qui
détectent les protéines qui se trouvent
dans le sang et même dans les excréments
des poissons cela leur permet de repérer
une goutte d'hémoglobine dans plus de
4,6 millions de litres d'eau c'est
l'équivalent de deux piscines olympiques
pour détecter leur proie c'est
redoutable prédateurs ont un truc en
plus
les ampoules de Lorenzi elle se situe
ici sur le museau et autour des yeux on
dirait des petits points noirs ce sont
des capteurs sensoriels qui détectent
les champs électriques générés par les
autres poissons c'est une sorte de
sixième sens qui permet aux requins de
dénicher les proies cachés dans le sable
ou dans les autres angles vous voyez
c'est super poisson sont très bien
équipés et parmi eux certains ont des
caractéristiques propres encore plus
étonnantes le requin baleine dont nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure c'est de tout
petits yeux très fragiles et pour les
protéger il n'a pas de paupière mais des
dents
c'est pour mieux nous dévorer des yeux
les dents c'est sans doute ce qui nous
effrait le plus chez les requins elles
sont très aiguisées peuvent atteindre 7
cm de long chez le requin blanc leur
particularité c'est qu'elle tombe et se
remplace constamment les requins peuvent
perdre tenez-vous bien jusqu'à 30 000
dents au cours de leur vie en fait on le
voit très bien sur cette mâchoire les
dents sont disposés sur plusieurs
rangées les unes derrière les autres et
elles avancent comme sur un tapis
roulant plus surprenant encore les
scientifiques ont découvert récemment
que les requins ont probablement les
dents les plus saines du règne animal le
revêtement extérieur contient du
fluorure un produit actif que l'on
retrouve dans la plupart de nos
dentifrices alors avec des chicots
pareils doit-on considérer les requins
comme impitoyables serial killer
et bien pas vraiment la plupart d'entre
eux ne représentent aucun danger pour
l'homme nos craintes reposent uniquement
sur leur apparence parmi les 500 espèces
de requins répertoriées la
quasi-totalité est inoffensive pour les
humains seul 5 espèces présentent un
danger pour l'homme le requin tigre le
requin-bouledogue ce sont ces deux
espèces qui rôdent autour de l'île de la
Réunion le requin marteau le requin
océanique et le grand requin blanc en
2022 on a compté 57 morsures spontanées
de requins c'est-à-dire non provoqué par
l'homme c'est le chiffre le plus bas
depuis 10 ans parmi ces attaques 5 ont
été mortels mais il s'agit presque
toujours d'un malentendu si certains
spécimens s'attaquent à l'homme c'est
parce qu'ils se sont menacés et qu'ils
veulent défendre leur territoire dans ce
cas on parle de morsure de défense elles
sont généralement superficielles le
requin ne cherche absolument pas à
manger l'humain en général ils le
relâche rapidement c'est ce qui arrive
dans 95% des attaques en revanche et
c'est nettement plus rare il peut
arriver que le requin considère l'homme
comme une proie potentielle parce qu'il
l'a confondu avec un autre animal un
phoque ou une tortue par exemple on
parle alors de morsure de malade reste
il mord pour se nourrir les morsures
sont alors très profondes et entraînent
de graves blessures voir la mort mais
ces attaques mortelles sont extrêmement
rares selon des chercheurs de
l'Université de Floride la probabilité
d'être mordu par un requin et de ne pas
survivre à la morsure n'est que d'une
chance sur 3,7 millions vous avez plus
de risques d'être frappé par la foudre
ok ok les requins ne sont pas des
mangeurs d'hommes mais alors pourquoi on
a une dent contre eux la peur des
requins ne date pas d'hier au cinquième
siècle avant Jésus-Christ l'historien
grec Hérodote décrivait déjà des
attaques de squale sur des naufragés en
Méditerranée avec le début des grandes
découvertes au 15e siècle les marins
traversent les océans et rencontre des
espèces de requins inc jusqu'à lors sur
la base de leur récit de nombreuses
peintures et gravures représentent
l'animal comme une véritable machine à
tuer au 20e siècle cette personne racine
à la suite d'une série d'attaques qui a
eu lieu en 1916 aux États-Unis un requin
remonte de Floride jusqu'au New Jersey
où il tue quatre personnes en une
dizaine de jours ce terrible fait divers
inspire un best-seller publié en 1974
aussitôt adapté au cinéma par un certain
Steven Spielberg il s'agit bien sûr des
Dents de la mer l'histoire est toute
simple un grand requin blanc terrorise
les eaux d'une station balnéaire
américaine en faisant plusieurs victimes
un petit groupe d'hommes par alors à sa
recherche afin de l'éliminer mais là les
chasseurs vont devoir faire face à un
véritable monstre en 1975 le film écrase
tout au box-office mais le revers de la
médaille est terrible pour les requins
la squalophobie se répand sur toute la
planète du jour au lendemain les requins
endos une de mangeurs d'hommes Steven
Spielberg dit-on regrette terriblement
il n'avait pas l'intention de ternir la
réputation des requins il voulait juste
faire un bon film et sur ce plan c'est
plutôt réussi alors une bonne fois pour
toute non les requins ne sont pas des
monstres sanguinaires en réalité ce
grand prédateur qui trône au sommet de
la chaîne alimentaire est aussi une
proie pour l'homme chaque année
tenez-vous bien en tue 100 millions de
requins ce sont eux qui devraient avoir
peur de nous et pas l'inverse ils sont
essentiellement victimes du Shark fining
une pratique qui consiste à les capturer
pour découper leur nageoire en
particulier l'aileron cette partie du
corps de l'animal est très prisée dans
la cuisine d'Asie du sud-est mais aussi
en Amérique du Nord et même en Espagne
les ailerons de requins se négocient
jusqu'à 500 euros le kg mais une fois
amputée les requins sont rejetés vivant
à la mer où ils agonisent lentement
l'animal est aussi chassé pour ses dents
et pour sa peau qui sert à fabriquer du
cuir son huile de foie qui est utilisée
notamment pour ses propriétés
anti-inflammatoires et quand ils ne sont
pas tués volontairement de nombreux
requins sont pris par accident dans les
filets de la pêche industrielle enfin
comme si cela ne suffisait pas ils sont
bien entendu victimes de la pollution
des océans comme tous les animaux marins
à l'arrivée les dégâts sont
considérables on estime que les
populations de requins ont diminué de
70% depuis 1970 c'est une véritable
catastrophe écologique car la plupart
des espèces sont indispensables à
l'autorégulation de l'écosystème alors
arrêtons de les chasser et
protégeons-les plutôt j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu et que vous porterez un
regard différent sur ces animaux merci
d'être allé jusqu'au bout de cette vidéo
c'est le meilleur soutien que vous
pouvez apporter à la chaîne à dimanche
prochain chers épicurieuses et
épicurieux
[Musique]